Avatar the way of water is here and it's
as epic as we hoped for but being the
second in a series of new movies there's
a lot to unpack as the film's final
scene Fades to Black warning spoilers
ahead Jake and natiri flee their home to
protect their children ultimately
seeking Refuge with a group of met kaina
on Pandora's Reeves however it takes
some convincing to get local leaders
ronal and tonawari to give them shelter
they claim that the Met kaina aren't at
War yet and that the presence of Jake
and his family will inevitably bring
Bloodshed to their Shores and that's
exactly what happens after Kiri has a
seizure from bonding with the metcaina's
spirit tree Norm flies in on an RDA
helicopter to help the vessel's signal
is detected by quarrich and his crew who
quickly set out to search the islands
for Jake they torture Navi kill animals
and put whole villages to the torch
ultimately driving the Met kaina to war
and while the final battle ends up being
a victory for the denizens of Pandora it
still comes at a heavy cost when Jake
tells tonawari and ronal that he is the
one the RDA is searching for the
response is hostile they blame him for
the violence threatening their Shores
and their right to do so it's foolish of
Jake to think that he can outrun
quarridge and it's even more foolish of
Norm to take a chopper right where they
are however it's also true that the war
would have probably found the mechanina
sooner or later the hunting of the
Tolkien is becoming increasingly
important to the RDA making open
conflict with the locals inevitable
Avatar the way of water spends a lot of
time exploring the nature of the Tolkien
the giant whale-like creatures that
ceaselessly migrate through the oceans
of Pandora we learn that the Tolkien are
extremely intelligent with brain's far
more complex than those of humans
they're capable of Music art mathematics
intense emotion and high level
communication even getting their own
subtitles when chatting with their Navi
kin all that development makes it even
more devastating that the RDA is hunting
the Tolkien mercilessly in an extended
action sequence we see Captain mix
scoresby and his team of Tolkien Hunters
brutally Target and immobilize a mother
Tolkien who refuses to abandon her Young
calf the humans then enter the
creature's mouth and drill a hole up
into its brain extracting a viscous
fluid that apparently stops human aging
scoresby tells spider that a single vial
of the stuff is worth 80 million and
that it has become the focal point of
the rda's operations on Pandora there
are a few interesting details here one
this Mission seems to have nothing to do
with the rda's main goal of preparing
Pandora for full colonization early on
General Francis Ardmore tells quarrich
that her job is now to make the moon
habitable for human settlement and yet
many of her forces are still just mining
valuable resources for Earth's Elite
additionally scoresby's dialogue
suggests that the Quest for unobtainium
has quieted perhaps that's because of
the navi resistance back in the forest
or perhaps it's for some other reason
quarge decides to use the violent
hunting of the Tolkien to lure out Jake
and it works afraid for the life of his
new Tolkien friend payakon who's been
Outcast by his clan for going against
their pacifist ways Jake's son loax
swims out to Three Brothers rocks to
warn him but by the time he gets there
payakan has already been tagged for the
hunt and the RDA are in route at the end
of Avatar the way of water Jake says
that his family's Unity is both their
greatest strength and their greatest
weakness
is our Fortress the latter proves to be
true here as all of the kids want so
desperately to help each other that they
all end up getting caught they stay true
to these Sully's stick together Mantra
but that puts them in the middle of
Harm's Way in a way Jake's love for his
children causes the big battle at the
end he calls in Norm because Kiri has a
seizure and he desperately wants to help
her leading the RDA right to him then
the values he's instilled in his kids
caused them to get captured and his love
for them forces him to make some
difficult choices with the kids captured
by quarrich and held hostage on his
giant boat Avatar the way of water
enters its massive multi-stage climax at
first it looks like Jake is going to
avoid violence he's fully prepared to
hand himself over in exchange for the
safety of the children and he encourages
the Met kaina to stand down in this
moment you can almost see Jake's
exhaustion written on his face and his
fear of what another battle could do to
his family he seems almost defeated
before the battle even starts but then
payakon intervenes in one swift blow the
Tolkien throws the entire RDA ship into
disarray launching its massive body
across the deck and causing widespread
destruction it's the exact opening the
navi need and they waste no time
springing into action Jake Natori
tonawari and ronal lead the charge while
pyacan continues his Rampage the Tolkien
cleverly manipulates the way the humans
hunt His Kind using scoresby's explosive
Harpoon against him and ripping off his
arm before sending the hunter to his
death it's easy to imagine how powerful
a whole herd of Tolkien could be in
battle but no others come to Aid payakon
and the navi it seems that despite the
violence being committed against them
they're still dedicated to their
pacifist ways it remains to be seen how
those convictions will hold up as
Humanity's plunder of Pandora continues
the franchise could produce some
interesting conversations about the role
of non-violence and the struggle against
depression but knowing director James
Cameron we probably won't get anything
that deep
as the sea Battle at the end of the way
of water winds down an eclipse brings a
brief Nightfall and the fighting
continues in the dark with the rda's
forces severely diminished in their
equipment mostly destroyed netam goes in
Solo to free the younger kids from their
bindings it's a great moment for the Big
Brother showing both how much he's
learned from his parents and how much he
cares for his family with the kids free
to nateam is ready to go but loac begs
him to help rescue spider as well the
young human spends most of the movie in
the Captivity of his reborn father and
lox says that it would be wrong for them
to leave him there reluctantly nateam
agrees and they manage to get spider out
as well albeit at a serious cost one of
the more interesting things about Avatar
2 is the less than traditional family at
its Center while three of the main kids
are Jake and natiri's biological
children Kiri is adopted and spider
isn't even Navi despite these
differences they all treat each other
largely the same embracing a no one left
behind policy for the whole clan it's
admirable and touching but it also gets
natayum killed it would be miraculous
for the massive Sully family to make it
through the way of water completely
unscathed and as you might have guessed
from General genre tropes it's the
responsible older brother who ends up
taking the fall netayum does his best to
get all the kids out safely but he
catches a stray bullet and dies soon
after surrounded by his family the loss
is brutal especially for natiri the
sullies end up going back to the ship to
rescue tuck from quarge's grasp but you
get the sense that natiri might have
returned regardless to seek Vengeance
the death of a firstborn child is no
light matter and the mother puts her
rage on full display by absolutely
wrecking the remaining RDA crew while
nateam's death is incredibly sad it's
made a bit less devastating by the
film's final scenes his body is laid to
rest on the sea floor in the tradition
of the met kaina and we see his parents
communing with his Spirit or at least
his memory by bonding with the spirit
tree in the navi Faith energy is only
ever borrowed as Jake reminds us in a
monologue sooner or later you have to
give it back to AWA while it's nice to
see Jake and atiri get a bit of
optimistic closure for their son's death
we still don't really understand what
they're seeing during the bond is this
just a memory or are they truly seeing
the Tam again perhaps future films will
further explore how this ancestral
connection works after absolutely
decimating Court's remaining crew and
arguably the best action sequence in
Avatar 2 nataria pulls an extreme tactic
to secure Tuck's safety quarrich emerges
with the girl held under his knife so
natiri responds in kind she grabs spider
pain and rage burning on her like an
aura and threatens to gut him if tuck
isn't released while kwarich scoffs at
first and claims that he doesn't care
about his son he quickly blanches
seemingly despite himself and lets tuck
go would natiri have killed spider in
the scene it's hard to say we're told
early on Via Jake's narration that she's
never fully trusted the kid but she
still seems to treat him with love and
respect the few times they do interact
it's possible that this was all just a
Gambit but it's also possible that
natiri wanted blood this is our home
unfortunately the way of water doesn't
give us much real character analysis
here to grab onto the film clocks in at
an absolutely bloated 192 minutes
leaving plenty of time to build up to
this moment with more Intrigue but
that's not what we get clearly James
Cameron is more interested in giving us
a sixth underwater swimming sequence
then a bit more character development
and the film sadly suffers for it even
still Zoe Saldana is so good here that
it almost doesn't matter if you thought
Avatar the way of water was done after
the whale fight or after natayam's death
or even after Tuck's rescue you'd be
wrong there's still more action mainly
in the form of Jake and korich's
dramatic Showdown the two start on the
sinking deck of the RDA ship battling
close-up with combat knives however
their duel quickly takes itself
underwater as the entire vessel begins
to flood for all the beautiful alien
creatures in Avatar 2 the film looks
most impressive when the performance
capture is front and center Jake and
quarch's sub-aquatic fight isn't just
the film's narrative climax but also the
Pinnacle of its technical achievement
James Cameron's underwater performance
capture technology truly shines here and
the fight itself is brutal to watch in
the end though Jake manages to choke the
older man out leaving him to sink to the
Bottom of the Sea given that quarrich
ultimately survives this battle you
might catch yourself wondering why Jake
didn't finish the job it seems he could
have snapped his neck thus removing any
chance of the villain coming back of
course you have to factor in Jake's
exhaustion he's close to death himself
by the end of the fight and it's not
ridiculous for him to assume that quarge
is out for good
as the RDA ship floods and sinks and the
sea is set Ablaze around it spider joins
his adoptive kin in seeking out Jake
Natori and tug what he ends up finding
instead is his father unconscious and
drowning on the ocean floor no matter
how much spider hates him he can't let
himself abandon him so he grabs
quarrych's limp body and drags him to
the surface this is a questionable move
to say the least just a few moments
prior quarch declared that he would
track Jake to the ends of the world as
long as he was alive saving the villain
and allowing him to escape could end up
dooming the sullies down the line and
since spider is basically a silly
himself it might seem odd that he
rescues his father however his
Allegiance still lies with the navi as
he rejects quarrych's invitation to join
him and quickly returns to his real
family Jake Champion is fantastic as
Spider throughout the movie and you can
see his inner turmoil play out on his
face he has no love in his heart for his
father but he also can't let him die
he's even more conflicted because
quarrich just gave up Tuck to save his
son's life looked at in this way
spider's actions make sense he's
begrudged repaying a debt and avoiding
patricide but it's clear he would have
rather simply not found courage at all
even so it's hard to imagine the sillies
being thrilled when they find out what
spider has done
Avatar the way of water is a story about
family Jake grapples with his
responsibilities as a father and feels
torn between his desire to fight and his
need to protect his children natiri
faces a similar dilemma as she's pulled
between her duties as a mother and her
larger Community however it's not the
parents who take Center Spotlight at the
end of way of water but the children
they're the ones who saved the day and
lead the way home using her ability to
compel the natural forces of Pandora to
obey her Kiri locates where Jake natiri
and tuck are trapped under the wreckage
of the ship she finds her mother and
sister and leads them out while loac
goes to find his father exhausted from
his battle with quarrich and panicking
at the rising water Jake tells his son
to leave him behind convinced he can't
hold his breath long enough to get out
but loac refuses to hear it bringing the
lessons of the film full circle he
encourages his father to calm himself
teaching him the same slow breathing
technique he learned from Soraya safely
away from the wreckage Jake places his
hand on his son and Echoes soraya's line
I see and for the first time he truly
does one of the big mysteries in avatar
The Way of water is Kiri and her special
powers born from the dead Avatar body of
Dr Grace Augustine Kiri grows up not
knowing who her father was or how she
came to be she tries to learn these
answers by communing with the metcaine's
spirit tree but a seizure cuts her visit
short here's what we know for sure
Carrie has an uncanny connection to AWA
and the natural forces of Pandora and no
one knew that Grace was pregnant until
after she was dead given these Clues
it's possible that the father mystery is
a red herring and that Kiri was an
Immaculate Conception created within
Grace's Avatar by AWA that would explain
how she can hear a was heartbeat as she
tells Jake and it would make her
incredibly important to the story going
forward of course there's no proof yet
that this is the case but it seems
likely Kiri is unique among all the
other Navi and she could be downright
Messianic after the battle with the RDA
ends and natayam is laid to rest Jake
tells tonawari that he and his family
will be moving on you'd think the chief
would be glad to see them go even the
amount of Destruction they brought to
his realm but he's not he encourages
Jake to stay telling him that his whole
family is now part of the Met kaina clan
in his closing narration Jake reveals
that he's decided to stay he says that
he can't save his family by running and
he's right running didn't stop the RDA
from finding him and it didn't stop
nateam from dying so with a new and
Powerful Ally at his back Jake decides
to stay and make his stand by the sea
what exactly this means for the Avatar
sequels is unclear will likely continue
exploring new locations and subcultures
on Pandora but the Met kaina will likely
remain Central to the plot a return to
the forests of the omatakaya would also
make sense given natiri's Heritage like
its predecessor Avatar the way of water
is largely about the balance of the
natural world this theme is channeled
into the cultural and spiritual beliefs
of the navi and the way of water adds
another interesting layer in the form of
the Tolkien showing another
hyper-intelligent species on Pandora is
a great way to further develop the
complex ecosystem of the world and it
further contrasts the ways of the navi
with those of their human oppressors
it's particularly telling that the main
thing sought by the RDA in the film The
Brain fluid from the Tolkien stops human
aging it's a tangible affront to the
natural cycle of life and death that the
navi holds so sacred quarrich Ardmore
and the rest of the human forces
continue to represent imperialism and
environmental destruction on the largest
scale the RDA is run by company men only
interested in the bottom line even at
claims of Humanity's dire circumstances
become more prevalent Earth is dying but
the RDA is still just trying to make
money it would be interesting to see how
the action on Pandora is pitched to
regular citizens and how they feel about
the moon's occupation way of water also
suggests that as in our world the fight
for the environment is being led by the
youth it's fun to see the young Navi
taking charge and it should be exciting
to watch them grow with the franchise
unlike humans they understand that the
value of the natural world is greater
than what we can take from it
the third Avatar film has already been
shot and is planned for release in 2024
according to Cameron and after the
events of the way of water there are a
lot of places it could go this time
humanity is still on Pandora in between
the movies and general Ardmore will
surely want revenge for the destruction
of her valuable whaling vessel with
colonization now the ultimate goal of
Humanity's presence on Pandora more and
more powerful tools of occupation are
surely on their way the navi and their
allies will have to join forces to stand
a chance fortunately they now have Kiri
on their side whose unique abilities
we've likely only scratched the surface
of she could become the key to freeing
the moon for good but she's still just
figuring out the limits of her abilities
and of course quarrich will be back to
continue his spiteful Vengeance Quest
against Jake and his family maybe he'll
reconsider his position after being
rescued by spider but given how outright
evil he is that seems a long way off
spider himself still seems smitten with
Kiri and loac and Reya are building a
solid foundation for a long-term
relationship these romantic threads may
become more important as the care
characters continue to age Avatar the
way of water is a huge step up from its
predecessor and with luck the next film
will be even better
[Music]